eines schönen tages wenn ich die welt
verschlingen
wenn ich das tue geht ihr alle qualvoll
zugrunde
gewiss wir haben eine koran ist mit bar
eine im grunde relativ konsequente
fortsetzung des films thema zuvor
gemacht hat spring break das war ein
meisterwerk
ich baue mir jetzt fast so etwas wie ein
gegenentwurf könnte man sagen zu
springen breakers klein erzählt von
dieser figur montag in einer weise die
fast ein bisschen zu prüfen ist denn
erscheint an dieser figur den
allergrößten gefallen zu haben und zwar
in alle ihrer expressivität dann höre
ich musik die welt halt wieder und
wieder
dann treffe ich die frequenz
bei der ich anfangen zu tanzen dann
bewegen sich meine finger es ist ein
film der sich vollkommen auf diese figur
ein da ist der sich in diesem strom
beginnt denn dieser mann erzeugt
bei ihnen kommt die kreativität aus der
landschaft in die erlebt aus dem
sonnigen us bundesstaat florida und aus
den substanzen die er sich zuführt
harmonie verein feiert sie das leben
befinde mich auf eine gute weise melo
könnte man sagen ja gleitet dahin er ist
nicht interessiert an höhepunkten es
gibt wenn man so möchte einen
kontinuierlichen höhepunkte
das ist die darstellung von matthew
amerikaner die er wird ganz und gar 1
mit dieser fuhr und dafür ist wieder
oben ganz und gar 1 mit der figur montag
der zeichnungsspanne auch ein film der
vor allem von den farben lebt von der
stimmung von der kamera arbeitet unser
art und weise wie er das licht einfängt
und der art und weise wie die atmosphäre
eines ewigen sommers eben auch
zelebriert und wie montag diese wirklich
unvergessliche figur muss man sagen dass
dann überhöht versuche die verbundenheit
mit der welt aufzusetzen einfach mehr
nach maine frei gerade auch als paar
sind mit spaß und sein vorgänger in
scream breakers etwas ganz besonderes im
amerikanischen kino ich würde auf jeden
fall empfehlen mit spaß anzusehen
nüchtern aber vielleicht selbst in
irgendeiner weise inspiriert das muss
fair und jeder selber entscheiden und zu
hause das hier auf xinxii ist bei dem
ausgebrannten ich bin absam ist von ganz
unten